discord is now valued at 15 billion
dollars after raising 500 million
uh this was led by dragoneer co2
fidelity and others the folks who tend
to invest in late stages before they go
public if you remember uh back on
episode 1190
microsoft was very close to acquiring
discord uh for a room in price between
10 and 12 billion those talks fell
through uh so obviously if at this
valuation uh they are now valued at you
know somewhere between 20 and 50 more
than they uh would have been valued in
that deal with microsoft
if you don't know discord it's a chat
room it's a chat room it's like aol chat
it's like you know yammer turned into
slack or aol chat
yahoo chat turned into yammer turned
into slack turned into discord so um and
it's but it's more for content that's on
reddit in other words content that young
people whether it's video games or comic
books or music would be into so let's
break down discord's numbers uh for
their chat service and we'll compare
them to reddit which is i think these
are very complimentary brands that are
both going to wind up going public i
think the two should merge and go public
they would be worth a hundred billion
together
that's the best idea uh that anybody's
gonna say in the next 24 hours on the
internet so somebody bookmarked that uh
discord was launched in may of 2015.
reddit was launched 10 years earlier in
2005.
so uh on a valuation basis discord is at
15 billion reddit's over 10 billion
um and reddit raised a 700 million
dollar series f in
this past august last month that means
they're about to go public if you're
wondering that's just a lot of money
those late stage investors are looking
to double their money in two years or
something like that maybe triple it in
two or three years so they're making a
late stage bet that they want to you
know they take a lot of risks before it
goes public and gets priced by the
public markets fidelity is in both their
rounds there are no fools they they know
that these services are not going
anywhere
reddit did not give an exact valuation
just over 10 billion
but we can assume uh discourse valuation
is a little bit higher so on a revenue
basis uh according to the wall street
journal
and some of the numbers we found uh
discord had 130 million in revenue in
2020 which was 3x in 2019. so tripling a
big number like 45 million is pretty
impressive it's hard to double big
numbers or triple them a high growth
stock in the public markets would be
over 20 year-over-year growth so in the
private markets we are really looking
for companies that triple triple triple
double double double something like that
sometimes you can get a triple triple
triple triple double double double uh
sometimes in the early stages you'll see
a company go 4 or 5 x year over year so
that's how these private companies kind
of grow
which means in 2021 with the pandemic
and people at home and discord getting
super popular who knows maybe they
tripled again maybe their revenue is 300
million now we don't know reddit did
between 170 and 200 million in revenue
in 2020 based on the numbers we found
online again private companies uh do not
need to give out their numbers but
sometimes they get leaked by investors
or somebody might give an estimate uh
they had uh confirmed 100 million in
advertising in q2 of 2021 so they're on
a 400 million dollar run rate that was
according to the series f announcement
so
based on my estimates if they two and a
half times their revenue uh that means
discord would be at 130 260 plus another
call at 60 or 70. you know you're you're
looking at
350 million in revenue let's take a
guess uh and
read it at 400 million pretty amazing
that they're both in the same exact zone
discord sells a 100 a year premium
subscription called nitro for servers uh
and when you purchase those
it makes your servers have more advanced
features and tools slack calls their
servers or their instances workspaces
reddit as you know has subreddits you
can think of those as forums if you have
nitro
you can do you know
a lot of extra little things like
personal profiles and hd video screen
sharing and file uploads or larger file
uploads discord currently has over 150
million monthly active users according
to bloomberg reddit said it had 430
million monthly active users at the end
of 2019 now reddit has been around a
long time and as you know when you've
been around that extra 10 years that's
why they have that big boost because
they get seo traffic you type anything
in these days
you're highly likely to have quora and
reddit come up reddit is kind of like
quora the q a site because anytime you
type in a question what you'll see in
google autofill if you say
uh what's a movie like tropic thunder
you'll see at the end reddit so people
now are adding the word reddit they're
appending the word reddit fancy word for
adding
at the end of a google search that's
when you know you've got a ball or
service is when people say give me the
answer i've read it in terms of servers
and subreddits 6.7 million active
servers on discord in 2020 according to
the business of apps if 20 of those
servers are paying 100 bucks a year
that's about 1.3 million customers at
130 million in revenue which was their
revenue in 2020. 20 seems high to me but
i i might go with 10 or 5 percent uh 3
million total subreddits according to
reddit's metrics page
you know which one of these is the
better service which would i rather own
well reddit's been around longer reddit
can add discord just like reddit added
images and got rid of imgur i think was
the service that was doing images
if they were both publicly traded i
could only own one that would be a very
hard decision to make i might go with
reddit because
of longevity but if i wanted quicker
returns in a shorter period of time i go
with discord so i think reddit more
stable never going anywhere and one of
the great lessons of reddit is that if
you just keep running a service that has
product market fit
it will not go away
reddit has never had a competitor
discord on the margins is competitive
but it's not going to get rid of reddit
and if digg had just stuck around and
the venture capitalist had not pushed
kevin rose to try to reinvent the
service it would still be running and it
still would be awesome okay
congratulations to discord
if you don't have business insurance you
failed one of the first steps of being
an entrepreneur startups should look no
further than in broker and brokers
technology saves you time and money
their prices are up to 20 lower with
better coverage than the incumbents and
you can go from sign up to quote and
purchase in just 10 minutes so when you
work within broker instead of business
insurance incumbents you're not dealing
with large slow corporations and the
sign up takes days not weeks the process
is transparent with no opaque pricing so
let's talk about two very crucial types
of startup insurance you'll know that
these are very much in the news
especially the first one cyber insurance
you have to have cyber insurance which
covers hacks and they happen more than
you think a lot of them
you don't hear about publicly right
because people are ashamed to have them
happen and they should have done a
better job but mistakes happen and
sometimes software is imperfect right
where a human is imperfect and they make
a mistake they use a weak password they
forget to put two factor on well you
want to have cyber insurance just in
case that happens plus
dno insurance this helps if your
directors and officers do something dumb
and you get sued very simple very
important to have cyber and dno so to
instantly buy custom built insurance for
startups go to inbroker.com twist
e-m-d-r-o-k-e-r.com
twist while you're there you're gonna
get an extra 10 off by using the offer
code twist pwist okay let's get back to
this amazing episode